cam newton you know i miss seeing cam
newton every week i miss hearing from
cam newton i miss watching him play the
guy is phenomenal and
if it's up to him he'll be back with the
panthers next year according to the
charlotte observer he said at a charity
event
i am not leaving the team they've got to
ship me off for me to leave in order for
me to leave they got to get rid of me
it's not up to me now look
i think he has to say that right i don't
think you play that publicly you play it
behind the scenes if you are looking for
a fresh start i think for cam newton
at a minimum you want to wait to see who
the coach is before you make any final
decisions about what you're going to do
and what you want to do in 2020. that's
the huge wild card for everyone will the
new coach want cam and will cam want the
new head coach and the staff that has
put in place to work with cam newton and
i think it's premature for anybody to
make any decisions about what they want
next year but i think cam has to say
that you're at an event in charlotte
right you're not going to come out and
say i can't wait to get the hell out of
here but we have to wait and see
what is configured by way of a coaching
staff around cam newton before we know
whether it wants him or he wants it
chris yeah that that's the the big thing
exactly right whoever that is going to
be that comes in are they going to want
to entertain the idea of yeah let's
let's i want to i want to start my era
my coaching era with cam newton as the
quarterback uh now cam is still
phenomenal when he's healthy but the
other piece of this puzzle is yeah he's
into his 30s now he played the most
physical brand of football we've ever
seen any quarterback in the history of
the nfl play and we're starting to get
little inklings of ooh is his body
starting to fall apart or break down to
a degree now i think like this like
genuinely believe he wants to stay in
carolina i don't think he's like looking
to make a move there i just think that
the competitor he is he is a fabric or a
piece of you know a fabric or the dna of
of charlotte he is no doubt the most
famous player to ever play for the
carolina panthers and i do think he
wants to deliver on bringing a
championship to the carolina panthers
too so i believe him in that sense you
know i do think he wants to stay there
and continue to be the face of the
franchise um but whether that happens uh
to me is one of the most intriguing
off-season stories that we will talk
about is what happens with cam newton
and is there trade offers or teams that
want to make a play for him to uh make
them their new quarterback
and here's the thing look he can act
like he's got no control over this
process he's got significant control
over it because fundamentally his
contract is very tradable the panthers
aren't going to cut him they're going to
trade him if they decide they don't want
him and
in order to trade him he's got to be on
board with the team he gets traded to
you don't just dump a franchise
quarterback onto any team you can do it
with
any other position you can't do it with
quarterback why chris because you expect
the quarterback to be essentially an
assistant coach on the field and to go
above and beyond what the average normal
player does show up early stay late
study film set the tone inspire your
teammates hold them accountable be part
of management except when it's time to
decide you know which players they're
going to keep and which players they're
going to add but you have to have the
quarterback be all in you don't want a
reluctant franchise quarterback that's
not going to work for anybody so if they
decide they're going to move on it's not
just like they can say we're going to
pick up the phone and send them to some
team out and you know wherever he's got
to be on board with it or that team's
not going to want him and so he does
have a lot of control over how this all
plays out yeah
from that standpoint you're right and
we're going into what the last year of
his deal right as well uh so there's a
lot to be there he has a lot of power in
this situation so that makes total sense
and you know hey yeah i think there's
some teams that would viably want him
this year i mean especially the chargers
i look at that and when we talk about
that all the time to where i go yeah
they'd be crazy to not want a guy like
cam newton a little star power out there
to take some attention away from the
rams
and he's got a lot of power to push his
way out of charlotte if he ultimately
decides he wants out new coach hey new
coach i'm not showing up at all for the
voluntary offseason program good luck
getting an offense installed without
your starting quarterback now that sets
aside the injury issue which may keep
him from participating anyway but
there's a lot of things that cam newton
can do to engineer the rest of his
career
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports